il préfère ne pas être identifié parce
qu'il a basculé dans la pauvreté après
le de cette sa femme
le retraité s'est retrouvé dans cette
maison de chambre de Saint Henri en 2018
mais l'hiver dernier un acheteur s'est
présenté
heureusement pour lui la Ville de
Montréal avait assujetti l'édifice à ce
qu'on appelle le droit de préemption ça
a permis à l'administration plante
d'égalez la première offre déposée et
d'acheter la maison de chambre ça permet
à quelqu'un qui est qui vivait dans une
dans une chambre de pouvoir conserver
conserver ce droit là conserver cet
habitation là sont chez lui sont nés son
cocon à l'abri de la spéculation à
l'abri de rénoviction 15 locataires
commandés peuvent demeurer ici leur
petite chambre est souvent la dernière
bouée avant la rue assurément il y a une
corrélation entre l'itinérance et la
baisse des maisons de chambre Hist à la
Ville de Montréal la Ville de Montréal a
exercée son droit de préemption sur plus
de 300 propriétés en tout genre des
bâtiments et terrains industriels comme
celui-ci dans l'est de Montréal ou dans
le quartier court des neiges une
vingtaine d'immeubles appartenant au
géant cuirprint comme d'autres poids
lourds du secteur que prit indique à
Radio-Canada être prête à vendre ses
vieux immeubles jugés peu rentables si
vous voulez vendre des choses qui pour
vous sont peut-être inintéressants parce
que vous pouvez pas faire assez de
profits comme vous le voulez alors son
russe à s'entendent sur un prix
raisonnable on pourra faire une
transaction Montréal a prévu 600
millions sur 10 ans pour des
acquisitions mais souhaitent obtenir
plus d'argent de Québec et d'Ottawa pour
augmenter la proportion de logements
abordable Canada on est largement en
dessous du 10% en Europe dans certaines
villes 30% du parc immobilier de
logement qui va de propriété publique
pour sur le secteur communautaire c'est
la principale solution les prix en Bonzi
ce qui fait que autant les familles
les manger les nouveaux arrivants
peuvent exprimer une difficulté à se
trouver un logement de retour à la
maison de chambres on rencontre et là
elle aussi préfère ne pas être identifié
malgré son loyer modeste elle doit
souvent sauter des repas il m'arrive de
dormir j'ai faim mais je dors mais je
sais que à la fin du mois je pourrais
payer mon loyer immigrantes étudiante
est souvent affamé une preuve du fait
que rendre le logement abordable est
plus pertinent que jamais ici David
gentil les radios Canada Montréal